hello and welcome to all daint a
creepypasta horror stories cooked to
perfection with a splash of red sauce my
name is cz and I will be your server
this episode today's story is about a
swan song from one of YouTube's most
promising young stars taken from us too
soon
her name christina grimmie let's dig
right in
I've always been strangely fascinated by
tragedy now don't get me wrong it's not
like I'm happy that terrible things
happen I certainly don't encourage
terrorism or anything but I have spent
many nights on the weird side of YouTube
studying 911 videos or watching houses
get swept away by Hurricane Katrina I
think we all have a small tendency for
our eyes to be drawn to the morbid just
look at how drivers stare at the
wreckage during a highway traffic
accident and in turn slow down the
traffic themselves I also think that our
curiosity with such things as a culture
is related to our love for ghost towns I
always think it's amazing when a place
that once had so much buzz and attention
becomes barren and empty so quickly
sometimes tragedy and ghost towns can go
hand in hand just look at Pompeii or
Chernobyl one night in late 2016 I found
a similar example a virtual ghost town
if you will while browsing YouTube at 3
in the morning before going to bed I
stumbled upon a video from christina
grimmie christina was a youtube singer
who was tragically shot and killed just
after her concert in Orlando back in
June this was a truly sad and scary time
for her fans and the community christina
was just 22 years old and she was one of
the first big youtubers to pass away
since she posted so regularly I imagine
fans were left with a much bigger hole
in their lives as compared to other
celebrity deaths as I clicked through
some of her videos and read some of the
comments I can see that many of her fans
saw her as a
and we're torn apart at her death she
even used to refer to her fanbase as her
friend base I came to think that I would
have been friends with her too
I hadn't heard about Christina until
after her untimely death but in looking
at some of her other content I started
to see what the big deal was she was a
beautiful girl with a beautiful voice
she was a self proclaimed Legend of
Zelda nerd and she even had a Death Note
tattoo I imagine we would have gotten
along very well had we known each other
naturally I did quite a bit of digging
watching videos and reading comments
there was a lot of pain carried on that
page but in a way her channel was a lot
like a ghost town sure there are still
occasional posts from her manager
including a memorial video and some
pre-recorded music videos but for the
most part it was a ghost channel in many
ways it served as a memorial with people
leaving their condolences on her
discussion page most of the comments
were fangirls talking about how much
they miss her with the occasional why
couldn't it have been keemstar comment
but by far the most interesting thing to
me is looking at those videos uploaded
right before her death some of her final
recorded moments on camera and seeing
people's reactions now that she's gone I
don't really know what it is I feel bad
for her and her fans but these videos
just activate my attention this led me
to start looking at some of the tribute
videos that have been made in her honor
and it's here that I stumbled upon a
playlist called christina grimmie
unlisted so I guess that Christina got
her start by doing mostly covers and
some of them have since been struck down
because of copyright while others were
switched to private or unlisted in fact
most of the videos on this playlist
couldn't be watched because they were
changed to private but the rest of them
were just unlisted but what caught my
attention was one unlisted video titled
final goodbye in
caps with a thumbnail of Christina
waving at the camera the video was about
five minutes long as I recall and of
course I clicked on it to see exactly
what this final goodbye video was less
than one second into the video I was
shocked with what I saw it was a video
of Christina in her room only her face
was covered in what looked like blood
and she was crying her eyes out as she
talked it looked like she had been
sobbing for hours she was holding the
camera and recording herself and it was
basically just shaking all over the
place my first thought was that this was
some kind of Halloween or April Fool's
prank that she had done but I looked at
the date of the video and it said it was
uploaded today which was obviously
impossible I was in complete shock it
had only a couple hundred views and
started with her barely able to get any
words out through all the crying I can't
remember all of her exact words but she
started talking in typical vlog format
save for the fact that she was sobbing
through all of it hey guys it's
Christina I just wanted to say thank you
for all the love and support that you've
given me over the last several months
and I'm
I'm sorry that I had to leave me like
this she was coughing and choking on her
own words as she spoke I want you all to
be strong I wish I could stay here with
every last one of you thank you guys so
much for being there and supporting me
along the way you guys were literally
the biggest part of me it was an
incredible journey and I'm so sorry that
I had to end this way I loved going onto
her so much because I get to see all of
your smiling faces and no one can take
that away from me no matter what I just
wish that I had gotten one final chance
to say goodbye I guess I wasn't alone
because when I scroll down to the
comments they were pouring in some of
them were as shocked as I was wondering
how this was even possible and trying to
analyze the situation others were just
overwhelmingly thankful for her coming
back to give them closure it seemed like
all of the comments that I saw were
positive ones
I guess because you'd have to be a fan
of her to be seeking out the video
before I got to the end of the video it
stopped playing on its own I got the
familiar and unknown error has a curved
message I tried refreshing the page but
it told me that the user had removed the
video I frantically went to her channel
to see if could be found but it was
nowhere I searched YouTube to see if
anyone had Rio de dit but it couldn't be
found I even tried to find that
christina grimmie unlisted playlist but
it seemed like that was gone too
I was trying to process what had just
happened had I dozed off and imagined
that I certainly didn't think so
everything seems so real it was so vivid
that I still can't get her face on that
video out of my head I was starting to
think I had imagined it somehow until I
went to her channel and looked at the
discussion comments several comments had
just come in saying things like thank
you thank you for everything
now I'm I'm not really sure
thanks for tuning into this episode of
all dainty creepypasta Kristina may be
gone but you can always go visit her
YouTube channel where her music lives on
speaking of music go check out OST maker
and put together the beautiful tribute
that you heard in this video you're
built this time came out 264 dollars but
if you like this video right now I'll
waive that fee and give you everything
you just listened to absolutely free
remember to subscribe to see these world
for new Horrors every other week and
I'll see you in the next one assuming we
both survive
[Music]